wir fragen nach bei unserem mann vor ort
hannes grafik hat die demonstration
beobachtet handels um am vormittag
lebens los und 12 uhr 5 uhr die demo
offiziell für aufgelöst erklärt von
seiten der polizei
dann dauerte es ungefähr bis 16.17 uhr
bis dann tatsächlich der platz geräumt
wurde wir haben es verfolgen können die
auch hier bei bils die wasserwerfer
wurden eingesetzt
aber nur praktisch einen regen haben sie
erzeugt wie fällt die bilanz aus war
dass demokratie sozusagen in action die
wir da erlebt haben auf der einen seite
polizei auf der anderen seite
demonstranten und alle haben einen guten
job gemacht wie siehst du das
also ich glaube nicht dass alle
demonstranten einen guten job gemacht
haben viele waren wirklich coole art und
weise und haben hier würde
verschwörungstheorien antisemitische
thesen und und wirklich unsinn geredet
aber es gab eben auch wirklich wie
philipp ja auch schon sagte ganz
vernünftige menschen und es war
demokratie ein beispiel gab es was die
leben eben gerade gesagt das gab die
mütter die sagen sie wollen dass ihre
kinder in die schule gehen es gab einmal
genauso eltern die gesagt haben wir
haben angst wenn wir unseren kinder in
die schule schicken und sind aber dem
schulz der schulpflicht verpflichtet und
müssen unsere kinder dahin bringen genau
diese diese beiden pole gab es hier die
haben sich getroffen und darüber hinaus
natürlich noch viele viele viele andere
meinungen die heute hier genannt worden
und kundgetan worden sind und daher war
das demokratie wirklich aus dem aus dem
lehrbuch
genauso die polizei die diesen spagat
machen mussten
einerseits die genehmigte
demonstrationen stattfinden zu lassen
andererseits eben die corona im
schutzmaßnahmen darauf hinzuweisen dass
die einzuhalten sind und dann aber eben
als die versammlung aufgelöst worden ist
dann doch aber auch mit augenmaß und mid
mid mid mid immer wieder versuchen auch
mit appellen an die leute diese
versammlung tatsächlich aufzulösen die
leute zu zerstreuen
und ich glaube das ist wirklich gut
gelungen heute so sagt es die
wasserwerfer waren im prinzip auf dusche
eingestellt und nicht auf mit harten
strafe
wie gegen wirklich gewalttätige
demonstranten die wasserwerfer
eingesetzt werden wenn sie massiv steine
oder flaschen gegen beamte oder andere
gruppen werfen
da gibt es ja ein breites spektrum oder
dienste wie zum beispiel die zahlreich
vor ort waren die wurden überhaupt nicht
eingesetzt
das ist ein zeichen von besonderheit das
ist ein zeichen schon sicherlich auch
höchster professionalität von seiten der
berliner polizei die solche aufzüge
natürlich auch gewohnt sind und
entsprechend das repertoire haben das
sind dann auch ansetzen können und
manchmal weniger harte einsetzen können
und ich glaube es ist ihm gut gelungen
sie haben gezeigt hier ist schluss sie
kommen nicht weiter sie können sie haben
den sturm auf den reichstag nicht
zugelassen diese hässlichen bilder wie
aus dem sommer hat es nicht gegeben
trotzdem war die polizei nicht so massiv
wie eben gegen straffällige
fußball-hooligans wenn sie ausschreiben
oder andere gewalttäter die eben die
straße zum kampfplatz erklären um da
eben mit mit aller härte des gesetzes
vorzugehen das haben sie wirklich
bewusst nicht gemacht es waren ja immer
noch leute vor ort die trotzdem
berechtigtes interesse hatten zu
demonstrieren die alte gesagt haben okay
wir lassen uns jetzt von diesen aufrufen
der polizei nicht gleich hier vertreiben
wir wollen trotzdem noch hier bleiben
und weiter unsere meinung kundtun
jetzt hat ja gerade das parlament gerade
erst begonnen zu zu debattieren und das
waren wirklich augenmaß und und toll von
der berliner polizei finde ich mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren